era Día de Mercado en moura una remota
localidad del centro de Mali los
Testigos afirman que las tropas
malienses respaldadas por hombres
blancos uniformados descendieron en
helicópteros y abrieron Fuego contra los
residentes el propietario de este puesto
del mercado fue detenido y llevado a la
orilla de un río donde miles de hombres
se sentaron con las manos atadas
cogieron entre 15 y 20 personas las
pusieron en fila o no 100 metros de
nosotros les hicieron arrodillarse y les
dispararon es angustioso es inimaginable
Es difícil hablar de ello doy gracias a
Dios por haber salido de aquello muchos
de mis amigos murieron allí
[Música]
Naciones Unidas dice que cientos de
personas fueron asesinadas en moura a
partir del 27 de marzo de 2022 la
investigación que llevó meses también
revela casos de violación a mujeres y
niñas
nuestro informe concluyó que hay fuertes
indicios de que más de 500 personas
fueron asesinadas
al menos 58 mujeres y niñas fueron
violadas o sometidas a otras formas de
violencia sexual
el informe no dice De qué nacionalidad
eran los combatientes extranjeros sin
embargo cita declaraciones oficiales
malienses sobre los llamados
instructores rusos que han participado
en el conflicto de 10 años con los
grupos islamistas el ejército de Mali
calificó el incidente como una operación
antiihadista Pero entre las víctimas
había unas 20 mujeres y siete niños el
informe incluye imágenes del lugar donde
se encuentran las fosas comunes